[Music]
okay everybody I'm so excited because
I'm with Aaron Moriarty today Erin I
have to ask your fellow cancer happy
almost birthday do you use any of those
cancer traits do they come into your
workflow with acting anything like that
you know not into my workflow I would
say like there's
not but they feel more personal than
work oriented do you know what I mean
um and I like will take things that like
resonate and leave the rest so it's not
something I like abide by as a religion
but I'm interested in it that's a very
cancer answer I like that now Aaron I
have to ask you post on Instagram that
Annie's going to be in her Vengeance ERA
this season four do you think it's gonna
be the best character Arc for Annie this
season of the boys I can't see it
getting any better if they make it any
better amazing but but but thus far yes
absolutely unambiguously yes awesome I'm
excited for you you're born and raised
New Yorker is this the coolest thing
ever having a world premiere it's
amazing especially just have family year
and I grew up close to here it's just
yeah of course it's so special awesome
everyone watch Aaron just crush it and
catch and dust thank you so much so much
thank you